this video is brought to you by
Squarespace whether you need a domain
website or online store make it with
Squarespace check out squarespace.com
forward slash visual politic for a free
trial link below in 1963 when it became
independent from the British Empire and
after its economy was devastated by the
Japanese occupation during the Second
World War
Singapore was nothing more than an
agglomeration of shanties it was a place
where every bathroom and kitchen was
shared by several families
[Music]
things the economic and social level
they were hard and they weren't very
different at the political level either
the truth is that Singapore's beginnings
they weren't all that promising see at
first Singapore United with Malaysia but
the Romans it didn't last very long
[Music]
just two years later in 1965 and after
several political and ethnic clashes
with the aristocratic and extractive
Malaysian government Singapore was
expelled from the Malay Federation and
was de facto forced to declare itself
independent and at this point the
challenge that faced this small
territory was absolutely huge Singapore
it was poor it had less than 2 million
inhabitants and it lacked any natural
resources it wasn't even self-sustaining
in terms of food and water
[Music]
but hold on a second because the story
that we all know it's a bit different
isn't it I mean today just five decades
later Singapore is an independent
country in this city state is one of the
capitals of the world and one of the
richest territories on the planet check
out this graph
[Music]
since 1960 Singapore's economy has grown
by more than 7.5 percent every year
we're talking about a huge growth rate
that is allowed Singapore to experience
the fastest development process in the
history of mankind today this city's per
capita income is much higher than the
United States and it is more than twice
that of middle-income countries like
Spain and it's almost four times that of
Chile which is considered the most
prosperous Latin American country
[Music]
and you really can't say that this isn't
quite amazing now the question we can
all ask ourselves is well how did this
tiny city-state achieve such a huge
amount of economic growth well let's
take a look at that takeoff
[Music]
[Applause]
folks this entire story it's got one
clear protagonist and that is Lee Kuan
Yew the autocratic Prime Minister who
governed Singapore between 1959 and 1990
drive around the world often and you
know people don't know that I come from
Singapore and they treat me as a Chinese
or as a in the old days it used
to call them now few people would have
bet that this country would end up
having a bright future and folks Lee
Kuan Hughes first years leading
Singapore they really didn't bode well
as secretary-general of the popular
Action Party apart either belonged to
the socialist international party this
Prime Minister initially flirted with
so-called import substitution
industrialization policies this is a
political approach that blindly commits
to protectionism as a way to achieve
development this was something that was
actually particularly popular throughout
the 20th century in Latin America and is
actually in a way it still is
[Music]
really in his first years of government
Lee Kuan Yew was closer to Argentine
politicians than to anyone who supported
the free market and globalization
however folks unlike what happens in
Latin America in Singapore they soon
realized that this type of policy was by
no means the best way to escape poverty
[Music]
that's why starting in 1965 a very
different approach was launched a
political and economic commitment that
transformed Singapore completely they
opened up to the global market when most
third world countries denounced the
exploitation of Western multinationals
in Singapore we invited them that's how
we achieved growth technology and the
know-how that boosted our productivity
more than any other economic policy
could have done Lee Kuan Yew now
Singapore hasn't been anything close to
a prototype of an orthodox and
libertarian state where the government
doesn't interfere in any economic
activity on the contrary the Singaporean
government has played and still plays a
very important role but before we carry
on let's just say that they did it in a
very different way than were used to
for example maths was the case in all
Europe things are changing quickly and
we're having to adjust and keep up due
to technology globalization we've had to
anticipate what's happening we have to
help companies and workers to adapt Lee
Hsien Loong in Singapore the government
didn't try to take over the larger
sections of the economy nor did they
attempt to regulate everything down to
the smallest detail nor of course did
they try to expand public spending and
taxes
quite the opposite in Singapore's case
we can basically think of it as a state
company or better yet a city company you
will know that's right you Stockholm
that is Lee Kuan Yew understood that
Singapore needed to attract capital and
professional so that the country could
grow and develop
[Music]
and with an imperfect competitive
environments between economies and the
heavy intervention that exists in the
countries we live in the state can play
a key role and it can do so with
policies that always favor
competitiveness investment and the
attraction of companies instead of
bureaucracy and welfare
[Music]
that's why the Singaporean authorities
developed institutions to guarantee
legal security and efficient management
of the city they promoted economic
sectors through public-private
collaboration drew up an ambitious
productive infrastructure program and
most importantly promoted savings and
that's not all all policies were
designed within a strict budget
stability framework and always always
with the mindset of integrating them
with private agents something that
rarely happens in countries like Spain
or Italy or of course Argentina
all right so allow me to explain
it isn't as much about expanding a port
or a road but being able to integrate an
attractive institutional framework with
services that cause companies to settle
in a country they want to encourage
companies to invest so they can increase
their productivity but let's put it
another way how the companies compete in
the market well they do that by offering
better conditions than the competition
right
[Music]
well Lee Kuan Yew he understood that in
our world competition between countries
is not very different therefore perhaps
the best way to see and understand the
keys to Singapore's success is to view
the city-state and not as a country to
be used but as a service provider in a
competitive industry in Singapore the
government understood that the community
itself the city itself was an asset and
thus well-managed it could become a
competitive advantage
but you understand this better let's
take a look at some concrete examples of
the policies that Lee Kuan Yew set on
the table first objective despite having
a city with a very high population
density turn it into a non chaotic
unknown and unpolluted place to do this
the government imposed traffic taxes in
1975 so today traffic in the city is
subject to tolls that are charged
electronically to all users on the road
that is to vehicles that way they manage
to impute the streets maintenance costs
do the real road users they manage to
avoid traffic jams and stop the build-up
of pollution the results of this
approach has been today's Singapore
despite having a very high population
density and being one of the economic
engines of the world has very fluid
traffic and in addition imposes
maintenance costs based on each drivers
use of the road that is if the benefit
you gain isn't greater than your toll
which is the maintenance cost of the
road itself then you can leave your car
at home and if the benefit is greater
than you have roads through which you
can move quickly it's really a pretty
smart system
of course to make this all possible
Singapore developed a fantastic very
efficient and affordable public
transportation system
another much more controversial measure
due to its paternalism is forcing all
workers to invest a quarter of their
salary into a rigid national savings
plan that's also managed by a state
organization with this program the
islands government gets workers to
accumulate savings with which they can
pay for health services educational
services and their own retirement and
while that happens the state gets the
capital it needs to invest in projects
in and out of country that are
understood as being essential for the
city's competitiveness in a certain way
workers don't only become users but also
investors in this city company
of course these types of interventions
where the state maintains clear
leadership are complemented by a policy
that favors free enterprise and one of
the freest regulations in the world in
terms of capital goods and worker
circulation folks in Singapore taxes are
low for example someone with a $60,000
income pays just 5% income tax tariffs
are practically non-existent there's no
minimum wage public expenditure accounts
for approximately 18 percent of the GDP
and if all that weren't enough
Singapore's economy is considered to be
the second freest in the world see in
the world we live in today being
peripheral or being central doesn't
depend on your country's physical
location it depends on whether or not
you have a room and an economy of
knowledge it depends on technology it's
the only thing that can explain what
countries like Singapore have a much
better education system than we do
Albert Riviera MP of Spain
the result of all this is that a country
that until a few decades ago is very
poor is now one of the richest countries
in the world and don't think that it's
just a matter of economics Singapore
also has some of the best universities
with students at the forefront of
subjects like science and mathematics
further their healthcare system is
excellent there's basically no
employment or crime ins their
expectations for the future are
extraordinary for example in the Human
Development Index produced by the United
Nations Singapore currently occupies the
tenth place above countries like Sweden
Iceland France and Finland
the negative side and there is one is
concentrated in its political system
which although it's still evolving is
still very restrictive of civil
liberties in Singapore prison sentences
a very high censorship is a normal part
of life and different behaviors to the
Norma usually not well regarded we're
going to talk about all of this more in
future videos because Singapore is one
of the most fascinating countries in the
world and it's a real magnet for
professionals from all over the globe so
I really hope you enjoyed that video and
before we wrap up today let me tell you
about Squarespace if you've got an
important message to share why not do
with Squarespace maybe you're like me
and you need a place on the web for
people to find you or maybe you're just
starting a new business and you need to
set up an online presence or store well
all of that is possible with Squarespace
on Squarespace it all starts with a
stunning template and with names like
pursuit and rice you know they're cool
but seriously they are very good-looking
templates or if you hate beautiful
templates not judging here you can start
from scratch
Squarespace make it super easy to make
something that looks amazing you can
also easily move over an existing domain
and if you've hosted a web site
elsewhere in the past you know that's
gonna be a good idea because hosting on
Squarespace is going to be easier and
once you've gone through that easy
customization process there's no updates
there's no patches there's no tech BS to
deal with because no one likes any of
that stuff but you know what people do
like Squarespace is 24/7 customer
support
they're there to help you whenever
you've got a question and Squarespace
isn't just about an online presence as I
said if you're starting a business and
wanna sell online Squarespace is a great
place to do it look whatever you're
looking to do online just do it with
Squarespace at squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com forward
slash visual politic and you'll save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
domain and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]